- I'm just talking with Bonnie Raitt
don't worry about America.
(crowd cheering)
We're back with Bonnie Raitt
this celebration of the 1980s,
because it's my birthday week.
So you, I heard that you briefly
worked with Prince in the '80s.
Is that correct?
- I did I did Prince
called me up and said,
"Hey, you know you weren't treated right.
Come on over to Paisley Park.
Let's make a record together."
- I Love that.
(crowd cheering)
- And um, I said if we can
meet in the middle, you know
I don't necessarily wanna
do a whole Prince thing
and you don't wanna do
a Bonnie Raitt thing.
- Yeah.
- So , I had a Ski accident
and fell on my thumb
and had to be in a cast for two months.
So I had to postpone working with him.
- This is why I don't work out.
- And then I was like, I was
like 35 40 pounds heavier.
And I went, you know
if I do a video with this
guy, if we, if the song works
and it's really sexy,
I gotta do something.
I said, I gotta, I gotta work on this.
So, I used the cast as
an excuse to lose weight.
And I just, I said you know
I better quit drinking too
because it gets, you know
in your thirties and you
put on pounds a lot easier.
- I I've noticed.
(crowd laughing)
- So I ended up hanging
out with some friends
of mine that were sober
and I went, you know what?
This feels really good.
So I lost 20 pounds before
I worked with Prince.
(crowd cheering)
- I love that that's what did it.
- And that's kinda what did
it cause I was so terrified
of being in a video with him and not not
like looking and saying all
that sexy stuff to me and going
"I don't think this people
are gonna believe that."